عندما تجري عملية جراحية على دماغ شخص ما
وتأخذ خزعة أو شيء لا
تتوقع أبدًا أن تواجه شيئًا حيًا،
لذلك كانت صدمة كبيرة لها
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
لذا فمن المحتمل جدًا أن يتم
توثيق حالات جديدة أخرى، لذا نأمل أن يتم
رفع ذلك  إن الوعي بذلك سيساعد
العاملين الآخرين في مجال الرعاية الصحية حول العالم
[موسيقى]
نحن نعلم بالتأكيد أن هناك طفيليات في البشر
يمكنها الوصول إلى الدماغ
وهي طفيليات معروفة لدى
البشر ولكن شيئًا بهذا الحجم يبلغ ثمانية
سنتيمترات ويتلوى وهو
شيء لم يحدث من قبل  لقد
شوهدت في إنسان كان بالتأكيد
شيئًا لن ننساه أبدًا
[موسيقى] لقد
كانت حالة غير عادية على العديد من المستويات
حيث
من الواضح أننا تفاجأنا بأننا لم نفكر أبدًا في ذلك
سنكون هم من
يكتشفون عدوى جديدة في العالم ولكننا
نعلم بالتأكيد أن هذا النوع من الأشياء
يمكن أن يحدث عندما
يقترب البشر وموائل الحيوانات من بعضهم البعض